في الواقع الحصول على الوقود هو الامه
الازمات هنا في جنوب شرق الخرطوم وفي جنوب
الخرطوم اغلب محطات البنزين مثل هذه
المحطه هي لا تعمل
وفارغه الحصول على الوقود بصوره عامه
يعتبر من المشاكل الكبيره بالنسبه للناس
وهو ملازمات والذي ادى الى ارتفاعي اسعار
النقل هو الذي ادى الى الدفاع اسعار
المواد الغذائيه في هذه المحطات التي تقع
في شارع الستين نلاحظ ان هذه المحطه كانت
مغلقه منذ الاحداث وهي واحده من المحطات
الرئيسيه في هذه المنطقه ارتفاع اسعار
الوقود اثر على كل مجريات الحياه في جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم اثر على عمليات
الاجلاء
الناس عمليات النزوح اثر ايضا على ارتفاع
اسعار
المواد التموينيه قصه الحركه قد تكون
مشلوله في عدد من المناطق بسبب ان الوقود
غير متاح وهو نادر في هذه المناطق والحصول
عليه
يعني امر صعب جدا يحتاج الى عدد من الناس
يحتاج الى شك من اشكال العلاقات يحتاج الى
ان تعرف الذين يبيعونه في السوق الاسود
بين بعيدا عن الناس لذلك معظم محطات
البنزين ومحطات الوقود في جنوب العاصمه
مغلقات حركنا في عدد من المناطق في الواقع
لم نجد ولا محطه واحده
مفتوحه في المناطق الشرقيه انا هنا اتحدث
عن شارع عبيد خاتمه تحدث عن شارع الستين
اتحدث عن شارع المطار اتحدث عن شارع
افريقيا كل المحطات الموجوده فيه كانت
مغلقه ولم تكون توفر الوقود